RYAN BOYD: Hello, everyone.
Hope you're all here today for
the Crunching Big Data with
BigQuery session.
It's quite early in the morning,
yet we still managed
to get a decent crowd.
That's exciting.
For those of you who have
colleagues that didn't make
it, you can encourage them to
watch the YouTube video
afterwards.
Hopefully, you'll like
the session.
My name is Ryan Boyd.
I'm a developer advocate
here at Google.
And I'm here with
Jordan Tigani.
And Jordan is a software
engineer on our BigQuery team.
So thanks, Jordan.
I'm going to give the
introduction here.
And then Jordan's going to come
back later and talk about
the exciting stuff.
All right, so the first question
that you might have
when looking at this slide title
is, what is big data?
Big data is a term that's
often used to represent
different things in the tech
press or in industry.
And for our session here today,
we really want to
define what it means.
So the question I have for you
today is how big is big?
How many of you think one
million rows is big data?
Is that big for you?
All right, a handful.
10 million?
All right.
100 million rows?
All right, we actually have
most of the audience there
with 100 million rows.
For us, 100 million rows is
kind of getting there.
But 500 million rows, come on,
give us some applause for 500
million rows of data.
[APPLAUSE]
RYAN BOYD: All right,
so 500 million rows.
BigQuery is really optimized
for hundreds of millions of
rows to billions of
rows of data.
It's a lot of data.
And you might wonder, what
does Google do with such
massive amounts of data?
Big data at Google, it's
really important.
And we've been dealing with big
data in this space or even
much larger, pretty much,
since we started.
A lot of companies haven't
really got into
that size back then.
But if you look at some of our
numbers here, we have 60 hours
of video uploaded to YouTube
every minute.
We have 100 million gigabytes
of data in the
Google search index.
And that was in 2010.
We haven't had an updated
stat here.
But in 2010, there were
100 million gigabytes.
And then, apparently,
now there are 425
million users of Gmail.
I just had to update this number
just now from 350.
So Google has services that
generate massive amounts of
data, that require processing
and working with massive
amounts of data.
Now, it used to be that
companies that wanted to work
with data would load it
on a database server,
something like this.
They would load all their data
on that database server.
And in order to process more
data, they would increase the
memory, add a few CPUs.
And it would get costly, but
it was all kind of stuck in
that single box.
Google really looked at this
and said, you know what, we
don't just have one server.
We have dozens, hundreds,
thousands of
servers around the world.
And we can use all of those
servers in order to process
our massive amounts of data.
But we needed the software that
enabled us to do that.
We needed software that we could
run very quick queries,
to process the data generated by
our products, to iterate on
those products and make them
better for our users.
And most of the software for
distributed computing on
large-scale environments like
this would handle the queries
that you wanted to do, but would
give you the results in
a matter of minutes or in a
matter of hours, not in a
matter of seconds.
And we really wanted that ad
hoc, iterative analysis to
improve our products.
So Google invented our internal
technology called Dremel.
Dremel is really a technology
that allows you to do SQL-like
queries on massive amounts of
data, hundreds of millions,
billions of rows, gigabytes,
terabytes,
large amounts of data.
You could do SQL-like queries
and get results quickly.
So what types of queries
do we use Dremel for?
Google uses Dremel for all sorts
of different things.
Google uses Dremel everywhere
from understanding our
products and our usage of
products to building things,
products like Google Books,
and in our Ads
environment as well.
So let's give you
some examples.
Here, the first one is going
to be finding top installed
market applications.
Whether this is the Google
Apps Marketplace, which I
worked on for a few years, or
the Google Play Store, or what
have you, this is the type of
query that we would do.
We basically say, give me the
top 20 apps and the count of
installs from an install log.
In this case, for 2012, we shard
our install log so we
can do all of 2012
in this query.
And we can get a result
on something
like that in 20 seconds.
And that literally is scanning
through every single row of
this install log and
getting us the
result in about 20 seconds.
But all of these products
need servers to run on.
And these servers sometimes
have issues.
And we need to monitor the
status of these servers.
So we also have an operations
team at Google, of course.
And this operations team still
uses the same underlying
Dremel technology to do things
like find slow servers.
So here is the query that we can
do to find slow servers.
All we're doing here is finding
the source machine and
the number of requests that
that source machine is
processing that are taking
greater than four seconds,
grouping that, ordering it.
And again, we have our result
in about 20 seconds.
This is really powerful for us,
because it allows us to
really drill down and
get the answers to
our questions quickly.
All right, BigQuery.
BigQuery is Google's
externalization of the Dremel
technology.
BigQuery gives you the power
to do this as well.
It gives you the power to
store your data with the
reliability, redundancy, and
consistency that Google
expects of its own data.
It also gives you the power to
go from data to meaning at
scale, quickly.
And that's what this
is all about.
So developers are using it for
as wide a range of different
things as Google uses
it ourselves.
Developers are using it for
game and social media
analytics, infrastructure
monitoring, advertising
campaign optimization, and
sensor data analysis.
A whole wide range of different
types of companies,
different types of data, but
BigQuery really allows them to
analyze their data quickly and
iterate on it and answer
questions that they weren't able
to answer before, because
they simply didn't have the
staff or the resources to deal
with data at that scale.
So our agenda here today,
I'm going to show you
the power of BigQuery.
I showed you a little
bit already.
We're going to actually
show it to you live on
some public data sets.
Then I'll talk about loading
your data into BigQuery,
running your queries.
And then Jordan is going to
come up and give you the
underlying architecture design
of how BigQuery works.
We really hope that, by diving
underneath the covers of
BigQuery and showing you how
it works, that it will give
you the intuition that you need
to understand how to form
your queries and get
the answers to the
questions that you have.
And for that, Jordan is also
going to give you some
advanced queries on, again,
some public data sets, the
GitHub data.
So one of the public data sets
we have is a bunch of the
GitHub commits from the GitHub
source repository.
And so Jordan's going to dive
into that and show you how to
do things like 7-day
active users.
So let's dive in.
BigQuery, at its heart,
is an API.
It's a developer interface
for you developers to
analyze your data.
But on top of that developer
interface, we've actually
built a UI as well.
And you can all access that at
bigquery.cloud.google.com.
You could do that now,
if you're sick of
listening to me--
hopefully, not--
or later.
But let me show you
some queries in
this interface here.
All right, so this is the
BigQuery interface.
Hopefully, you can
all read it here.
And on the left-hand side, we
have the public data samples.
These are all our public data
sets that we've made available
on BigQuery, like I said,
the GitHub time line.
But some of the other things
here are things like
Shakespeare, words in the
Shakespeare vocabulary,
Wikipedia, all the revision
history, et cetera.
But the one I'm going to dive
in here today is the
natality data set.
And the natality data set is a
record of all births in the
United States in the last
40 years or so.
So every single birth in the
United States is recorded in
this table.
And let's see how big that is,
how many people were born in
the last 40 years or so.
Any guesses?
Shout out a guess.
How many people were born since,
I think it goes from
1972, something like that.
AUDIENCE: 100 million.
AUDIENCE: 500 million.
RYAN BOYD: All right, so some of
you made some guesses from
hundreds to 300, 500 million.
We'll just do a simple
COUNT(*) here.
And I have it zoomed-in, so
we need to scroll down.
It's actually 137 million rows
in this table, so we're
getting to be at the
point of being big.
It's not quite as big as
BigQuery is able to process.
But it's a great demonstration
data set, because it's some
interesting data.
So you saw I just did a
simple COUNT(*) here.
BigQuery doesn't do indexes, so
this went over all of the
data and did a count of it.
So let's actually show
you what some of this
data looks like here.
And I'm going to zoom out
a little bit here.
I'm going to query this table.
And we have a bunch of fields
here, so the year, month, day
of births, the state, whether
the child's male, race, weight
of the child, whether the child
was a twin, some health
data on the mother, all sorts of
different data that we have
about children in
this data here.
And this comes from
the US government.
Believe me, this isn't
the type of data
that Google has directly.
But anyway, so we're selecting
all that information.
And we're going to say for
a particular date here.
So where year is--
call out a year, someone.
AUDIENCE: 1986.
RYAN BOYD: 1986 is what
I heard first, 1986.
And a month?
AUDIENCE: How about April?
AUDIENCE: October.
RYAN BOYD: I heard April first.
And a day?
AUDIENCE: Seven [? or nine. ?]
RYAN BOYD: Seven.
All right, so April 7, 1986,
give me all the children that
were born then.
And how many children
were there?
And we can see we're crawling
across this data set, 4.3
seconds, processing 13.1
gigabytes of data.
And that's 13.1 gigabytes of
data in the columns I touched.
There's more data here,
but we store this data
in a columnar format.
So these are the columns that
I've touched, 13.1 gigabytes
of data, 4.3 seconds.
And it looks like we
had 10,000 babies
born on that day.
And we can restrict it down
and then say we're in
California, go into
California.
So this is the ad hoc, iterative
analysis that
BigQuery is so great at,
producing results in just a
handful of seconds here across
large scales of data.
So 1,378 in just California.
But one thing I want
to show you.
So we had 13.1 gigabytes
of data.
Let's say that we don't need
a lot of this information.
And we just restrict it down
to a handful of columns.
And so, in this case, we went
over 4.92 gigabytes of data.
So BigQuery actually bills based
off of the amount of
data that you touch when
running your queries.
It's $35 a terabyte.
And so, in this case, we've
only processed on 4.92
gigabytes of data.
You only have to select the
columns that you're really
interested in looking at.
And you'll only be billed for
the columns that you select.
All right, so we have this.
Now, I promised you that
BigQuery is actually a
developer interface.
So let's look at something that
is built on top of it.
This is an example.
This is a company called
QlikView, which is a
visualization provider.
And they've built a connector
for BigQuery.
And this connector for BigQuery
allows you to
visualize any of your data
that's in BigQuery.
And one of the demos that we
launched last week was this
QlikView demo on top of the
birth statistics data.
And you can drill
down onto it.
You can filter all the data.
And its running live queries
against BigQuery.
So check this out.
And there was another
one of the demos--
sorry, I guess I loaded
this earlier when--
but you can check this out.
We launched, actually,
another demo with a
partner called Bime.
And that demo is on the same
data plus some business data,
another visualization
provider.
And we'll have more and more
third-parties in our ecosystem
releasing things too.
All right.
But let's show you how to
actually do this yourself.
So over here, I have a
Google spreadsheet.
And this Google spreadsheet
has a big button here that
says, "Run Query, Run." I'm
going to click that.
And what this is going to do
is actually execute a query
against BigQuery and going to
put the results of that query
into the spreadsheet.
And the data that we're
looking at here
is a couple of things.
We're looking at the average
age of the first birth of a
mother, so a mother's first
child, how old was the mother,
and the average weight of that
baby broken down by year.
And then you'll see, column B, I
actually added something for
my personal fun experimentation
here, and that
is red state or blue state
in the 2008 election.
So how does the weight of a
mother and/or the age of a
mother's first birth differ,
depending on whether the
mother was in a red state
or a blue state.
And for those of you who aren't
from the US, red state
is Republicans, blue states
is Democrats.
And let's look at that.
So we have the data here.
And then I've actually created
some pivot tables in advance
that wait till we
get the data in.
And this is the birth age of a
mother for her first child in
a blue state versus red state.
Even I did not expect this wide
of a difference here.
It looks like we're at about
24 for the red states and
about 25-ish for the
blue states.
There's almost a year
difference, or maybe even
more, between the age of a
mother at her first birth in a
blue state versus a red state.
So it's fun data.
And baby weight.
Now, I'm not a doctor here,
but this is pretty
interesting.
Back in 1970--
sorry, I didn't format the
bottom there, but those are
the years--
back in 1970, the age
was about the same.
The age of a mother--
sorry, the weight of babies
was about the same.
But then, as we proceeded
forward to present day, it
looks like blue state babies are
heavier by a decent margin
than red state babies.
And really, I'm not a doctor.
I don't want to explain why
that is, but it's just
interesting data.
So you might be curious
as to how we did this.
And we did this with
Google Apps Script.
And I'm just hopping over
to the script editor.
So how many of you have used
Google Apps Script before?
I'm curious.
Wow, a lot of you.
All right, this is fantastic.
I don't need to explain
too much.
But for those of you who
haven't, JavaScript-based
language executed on the server
side integrates with a
lot of Google APIs.
But up at the top here,
we basically
have a query defined.
We have then something that's
getting our active
spreadsheet, a method's
spreadsheet.
And then we have a single line
here that's executing our
BigQuery query.
And it's running
asynchronously.
So here, we're then looping
through and checking for the
result of our query every
500 milliseconds.
And when the result is complete,
then we're just
outputting the data to our
Google spreadsheet.
So 67 lines of code with a lot
of formatting that could
probably fit in about 50 lines
of code to get these results
from BigQuery and populate them
into our spreadsheet and
then run analysis on it in the
spreadsheet, which is a tool
lots of people are
familiar with.
All right, so let's talk about
how you do this yourself, how
you get your data
into BigQuery.
The first thing that you
should be aware of is,
typically, when you're working
with databases, you're doing
what's called denormalizing
your data.
You're basically taking your--
sorry, you're normalizing
your data.
You're basically taking
the duplicate records
and removing them.
So for instance, if we have a
birth_record table here and
then we have the parent's
record, if the same parent
gave birth to multiple children,
they would only have
one row in the parent record
and many rows in the
birth_record table.
With BigQuery, we actually
denormalized this data.
And we put it all
into one table.
This actually makes it a lot
more efficient to run our
queries and do our analysis.
And BigQuery really is meant
for that analysis part.
It's not meant to constantly
be updated or
anything like that.
You can append to it, but you
can't update the data in it.
It's really meant for
this analysis.
So you load the data in in
a denormalized fashion.
And that makes it a lot faster
for us to do analysis.
And then Jordan will talk
more about why that is.
But you load it in in a simple
format called CSV.
You all probably recognize
what a CSV
format file looks like.
It's really simple.
You get your data in this CSV
file, load it into BigQuery.
And you can load it in either
coming directly from your
machine to BigQuery, or you can
use Google Cloud Storage
as an intermediary as you
load your data in.
And that is a lot better from
a performance standpoint and
handles larger amounts
of data.
So once your data's in, you
need to run your queries.
And I've shown you how to do
it in Google Apps Script.
But we have a variety of
libraries, Java, Python, .NET,
PHP, JavaScript, Apps Script,
more, Ruby, Objective-C--
I think there are even others,
all sorts of different
libraries that you can use
to run your queries.
And they're all as simple as I
showed you with Apps Script.
It's really just, you
define your query.
You send your query over.
You look for a result.
And then you get the results.
But of course, it's
a REST-based API.
So you can do this in any
language you want.
If you feel like coding in COBOL
and COBOL has some new
HTTP package or something like
that, then feel free to use
BigQuery from your COBOL.
All right, I'm going to invite
Jordan back up here.
And Jordan, like I said, is
going to give you, really, for
those geeks in the crowd,
those data geeks, the
underlying architecture
of BigQuery.
And hopefully, you get some
intuition about how to build
your own queries.
JORDAN TIGANI: Thanks, Ryan.
Can you hear me?
RYAN BOYD: Uh.
JORDAN TIGANI: Hello?
RYAN BOYD: Do you have
your mic on?
JORDAN TIGANI: Hi, everybody.
I'd like to start with
a quick poll.
How many of you have ever
written any kind of--
RYAN BOYD: Is his mic on?
JORDAN TIGANI: [INAUDIBLE]
or whatever process?
Well, a lot of you.
How many of you [INAUDIBLE]?
It looks like there is
a bunch of people.
So how many of you would run
a regular expression
[INAUDIBLE]?
All right.
[INAUDIBLE].
Not so many.
I appreciate it.
So [INAUDIBLE] lot of experience
[INAUDIBLE]
when you have had that bad
experience, you learn what
works, what doesn't work,
[INAUDIBLE] your data,
[INAUDIBLE].
So BigQuery [INAUDIBLE].
[LAUGHTER]
JORDAN TIGANI: Wait.
I have to get a picture
of this.
Come on.
[LAUGHTER]
JORDAN TIGANI: Wow.
OK.
Hopefully, you'll be able
to hear me now.
[APPLAUSE]
JORDAN TIGANI: All right.
So BigQuery is a totally
different, fundamental
underlying architecture.
And so the intuition you have
about what's going to run
fast, what's going to
run well isn't going
to hold up any more.
There's no such thing
as an index.
And as Ryan mentioned, you
should denormalize your data,
instead of normalizing it.
And actually, running a regular
expression over every
row in a large table isn't
really any slower than just
counting the rows
in that table.
So hopefully, by the end of this
talk, you'll have learned
a little bit about how BigQuery
works and can use
that knowledge to develop some
intuition about what kind of
things are going to run fast,
what kind of things aren't
going to run fast and how you
can make them run faster when
you do run into roadblocks.
So to start out with a little
review on the relational
database now, virtually every
relational database uses the
same fundamental data structure
to access its data,
whether it's MySQL or
SQL Server Oracle,
and that's the B-tree.
The B-tree is an on-disk
data structure.
And it's primarily good at
finding things quickly.
So it's sort of like a binary
tree, only with
a much larger fanout.
So a query comes in.
It starts at the root.
Let's say you're looking for
a particular customer ID.
That will tell you which of
the children to look at.
And you keep iterating down the
tree until you actually
find the data.
And that's great when you have
one of these B-trees.
Let's say this was
customer ID.
Well, what if you're looking
up transaction ID and you
don't have an index?
Does anybody know what
would happen?
Anyone?
AUDIENCE: Table scan.
JORDAN TIGANI: Table
scan, exactly.
I had to have a plant
in the front row.
So a lot of the underlying
theory behind databases has
been around for a long time.
People don't usually
realize how long.
But even so, this guy was
way ahead of his time.
[LAUGHTER]
JORDAN TIGANI: But what I think
he was getting at is
that, when you have really large
data, it's going to take
a long time to do
that table scan.
And on modern disk hardware,
it's going to be about three
hours to scan over an
entire terabyte.
And this becomes problematic
when you're trying to do ad
hoc type queries.
And an example I like to use
is top-level domains, so,
like, whether it's
a .net or a .com.
And let's say you're looking
for who accessed your site
from various--
or who referred to
your site from
various top-level domains.
And you want to do a
GROUP BY on that.
In a relational database, you
would first need to create a
column that had the top-level
domain, because you can't
really index on the
end of a field.
And then you need to create an
index on it in order to do any
kind of reasonable query.
That can be, really, a pain in
the butt if you're just trying
to figure out if this
is interesting.
So you don't want to spend a
half hour or an hour just
indexing something so that you
can run a simple query to find
out if it's valuable.
And a lot of the complexity of
databases is really designed
to avoid doing table scans,
because they're so expensive.
So some folks at Google realized
that they want to
continue to run ad
hoc queries.
And the data is getting
bigger.
And so it's harder and harder
to avoid table scans.
And they just said, what if we
don't bother avoiding the
table scan?
What if we just embraced
it and make it fast?
And so their goal was to perform
a one-terabyte table
scan in a single second.
And being Google, we don't like
to scale anything up.
We don't like to buy
expensive hardware.
We like to buy more hardware.
So if you just think about how
many disks you need to run
that, it's a lot of disks.
How many processors you're going
to need, if you're not
going to pre-aggregate and
pre-calculate things, it's a
lot of disks.
Luckily, being Google, this
kind of hardware is not
considered a lot.
If you guys saw the Compute
Engine keynote yesterday,
100,000 cores is where it starts
to get interesting.
5,000, not such a big deal.
So if you're resigned to do a
table scan, you don't really
need a data structure
that is designed to
look things up quickly.
And so they use the
column store.
And column stores are very
popular right now.
There's even a column storage
engine for MySQL.
But essentially, the way they
work is, instead of storing
things in record order format
where you store an entire
record sequentially in the file,
you store every column
in a separate file.
And there's two advantages
to that.
The first is, if you're only
querying over a couple of the
columns, you only have to
read those columns.
That's pretty simple.
The other thing is that
columns tend to
compress very well.
And compression algorithms
tend to work by removing
redundancy.
There's not a whole lot of
redundancy within a row.
If you think about it, if you've
got user ID, phone
number and user's favorite
color in your table, that
information, there's not a
lot of redundancy there.
But if you just look at, say,
the user's phone number, a lot
of phone numbers look similar.
Or user's favorite color,
there may not be
many favorite colors.
There's plenty of opportunity
to do compression there.
So that will get you,
maybe, one or
two orders of magnitude.
We're still not anywhere near
where we would need to be to
be able to do this sort of
one-terabyte table scan or
interesting queries over
data that size.
So we're going to have to figure
out how to re-architect
the actual computation.
And so some of you may
say, oh, well, why
not just use MapReduce?
MapReduce is a technology that
was invented at Google.
We released a white paper,
I think it was
about 10 years ago.
And there's a popular open
source package, called Hadoop,
that's the open source
implementation to that.
Has anyone used Hadoop
in the room?
OK, we have a bunch
of Hadoop users.
Any of the people that use
Hadoop, would you use Hadoop
to do interactive queries?
OK, not many.
Hadoop is a fantastic product.
I mean, it's very cool.
It will solve a lot of
problems for you.
But if you really want to do
iterative interactive style
things, it's not necessarily
the right tool to use.
And in order to understand why
MapReduce wasn't used for
this, I want to go into a little
bit of the architecture
of MapReduce and hope that
I can do this quickly.
So MapReduce has a single
controller that commands a
bunch of workers.
And the workers are actually,
true to their name, going to
do the actual work.
So the first step is map.
And map, you basically run a
single computation over the
entire data set in parallel.
And you output some other
information, usually key value
pairs that are used
by the next stage.
Next stage is, surprisingly,
reduce.
Reduce takes those key value
pairs, and everybody that got
the same key will go to
the same reducer.
So say we're doing a GROUP BY
the user's favorite color.
Everybody that liked purple
would go to the same reducer.
And say we were trying
to count those up.
The reducer would count those
up and then would write the
results back.
And hey, that's awesome.
That should be pretty
fast, right?
There's a problem in that
there's a step that I skipped
over, called shuffle, that
people usually don't think
about, because it's
not in the name.
It's not in MapReduce.
But it really should be
MapShuffleReduce.
And shuffle is slow.
I don't know if any of you guys
caught the Compute Engine
talk yesterday where they
showed a partner had run
TeraSort over one of their data
sets using a 1,000-node
cluster on Compute Engine.
And they did it in about a
minute and 20 seconds.
And that's very close to the
world record for that speed.
So even world record speeds
for shuffle are
still going to be slow.
And the other problem is, for
interesting queries, you may
have to do multiple passes
of map and reduce.
You can't always just do
one map and one reduce.
So obviously, we're going to
look somewhere different for
figuring out how to perform
this computation.
And I like this quote a lot.
It's from the late,
great Jim Gray.
But he basically said you need
to move your computation to
the data when you're working
on large data.
So that just informs a little
bit of how BigQuery
architecture works.
And so this is what
it looks like.
Does that look familiar
to anybody?
So this is the same slide
as the B-tree slide.
But the key difference is,
these boxes are no longer
on-disk data structures.
These are actual server
machines.
These are actual compute
nodes that have
disk, processor, RAM.
And so the way it works is
the query comes in at the
root of this tree.
The query is transformed and
sent to its children.
And it's transformed so that
it operates over smaller
portions of the data.
And then it's sent to
the next level.
And each one of those will then
read the data, perform
the query, and pass results
back up the tree.
So one way of thinking about
this is it's kind of a B-tree
index built on-the-fly.
Another way of thinking about
it is it's kind of like a
MapReduce, with the bottom row
being the mappers, the next
row being the reducers and the
top row being the controller.
But you don't have
to do a shuffle.
You have a very high bandwidth
connection between the mapper
and reducer.
And it's very easy to do
multiple rounds, because it's
essentially just another RPC.
And finally, a way of looking
at it is, basically, it's a
way to decompose relational
algebra into
the parallel portions.
For example, many of the
aggregation functions can be
paralyzed while the total sum
of a partial sum is just the
sum of the partial sums.
And so I want to go into a
couple of examples of actual
SQL and describe how this
is going to work.
So for simple aggregates,
COUNT.
If you think about how this
works, it's just, each node
counts the data, passes
the sum back up.
And then you get the total
sum at the end.
MAX is just the maximum of
the partial maximums.
STDDEV, there's an
online algorithm
for standard deviation.
Or you just need to keep
track of the sum
and the sum of squares.
The first two are going
to be very easy in
a relational database.
COUNT is probably just going to
be metadata on the B-tree.
MAX, you just have to read down
one side of the B-tree.
But a relational database would
be hard pressed to do
standard deviation.
It's possible that it could
work, but really, it's
probably not going to work
without a table scan.
But here's an example of
something that a relational
database won't be able
to do very quickly.
And here, we're doing complex
string operations or we're
doing a regular expression
or a string containment.
And this is essentially no more
difficult for BigQuery
than those aggregations
on the previous slide.
Another thing that you will use
a lot in BigQuery that you
may not use as much in
relational databases is the
nested SELECT or
the subselect.
And the reason this is often
very slow in relational
databases is because the query
optimizer has a hard time
reasoning about the inner
SELECT statement.
But BigQuery, it's pretty
straightforward.
When you're resigned to doing
a table scan, you don't have
to worry quite so much about
how you perform the query.
And I'll show you an example
of that a little later.
BigQuery also supports JOIN.
And we call it small join.
And so what that means is
at least one of the
tables has to be small.
And I think this is best
explained by a picture.
So small join, we take the small
table and we send it to
every single node in the
computation tree.
And then the large table is
read as normally, but each
node then gets to perform its
portion of the join and pass
the results back up.
But you can see why the small
table has to be reasonably
small, because we have to send
it to thousands of nodes.
And I wouldn't be doing my job
if I was just talking about
how awesome BigQuery was and the
things that worked really
well and I didn't mention
the warts.
And one thing that people tend
to find when they start using
BigQuery is they
hit the dreaded
"Response too large" error.
And so, in this case, we're
trying to select a couple of
fields from a very large table
without applying a filter.
And if you think about
this, say we have
a terabyte of data.
We're reading that
terabyte of data.
And then we're passing that
to fewer and fewer nodes.
And eventually, it's got
to go out the top.
So you're going to try to send
a terabyte of data through a
single node.
That's not going to work well.
So BigQuery disallows that.
Generally, you can get around
this by adding a limit clause.
And usually, you didn't really
want to get that
terabyte of data back.
You probably are just interested
in seeing a few of
the results.
There's another case where
you'll get a "Response too
large" error.
And it tends to be
non-intuitive.
And that's when you're doing a
GROUP BY, and you have a lot
of values in a GROUP BY.
And what's essentially happening
is that, say you're
doing a GROUP BY and then you're
doing an outer COUNT.
So you're just returning
one value.
It seems like, well, I'm just
returning one value.
Why should I get a "Response
too large"?
But as data is passed between
the levels, that can,
essentially, have
too many rows.
And that often happens with
a large GROUP BY.
A trick to get around that
is, essentially, to
sub-sample the results.
It doesn't sound very nice, but
you can statistically get
a very good sampling of the
underlying results.
In this case, we're using the
HASH function, which is sort
of like [? getHashCode ?]
in Java.
But it's a bit stronger than
that, a bit more resistant to
collisions.
And we're hashing the user IDs
and taking 1/10 of them.
And I'll show you, when I get
to the queries, how this
actually can be a very
good approximation.
One more case that's related to
GROUP BY that BigQuery has
a workaround.
If you're doing a GROUP BY and
an ORDER BY, so that you can
essentially get the most popular
things or the top
things, you can use
the TOP API.
And the TOP API is a statistical
approximation, but
it's an extremely good
statistical approximation.
It was designed by
statisticians.
And it's used heavily
at Google.
And that can get
you out of some
"Response too large" holes.
OK, so I'm going to
go to the demo.
And the situation here is,
you're in the middle of a
flame war on Hacker News about
which programming languages
are the most awesome.
And you've got three factions.
You've got the static language
fanatics that say that static
typing is the best.
You've got the dynamic language
zealots who think
that dynamic languages allow
you to code faster.
And then you've got the
functional programming
eggheads who feel like
functional programming hurts
your brain.
And anything that hurts has
got to be good for you.
And so what we want to do
is we want to solve this
once and for all.
And we want to jump
into the fray.
But we want to actually back
it up with data, unlike,
perhaps, some of the
other people
involved in the argument.
And so we're going to use
the GitHub data set.
And we want to compute the
relative popularity of these
types of languages over time.
And to compute the relative
popularity, we're going to use
the 7-day active metric.
And that's the number of people
that have been active
in any of these languages
over a 7-day period.
And we want to do this
in one query.
All right, so here's
that query.
Isn't that great?
Don't bother trying to read
this or understand this.
I'm going to build it up from
the constituent pieces.
But this will be online
afterwards.
We'll post a link that you can
look at these in more detail.
So this, it's got four
nested SELECTS.
It's got several GROUP BYs.
And it's got a JOIN.
Trust me, it's a cool query.
But I want to start with
something simpler.
And so, in order to get our
7-day actives, we only need
three fields from the
over 200 that are in
this GitHub data set.
And so we're going to use actor,
which is a person who's
making changes, created_at,
which is the time that they
made the change, and
repository_language is which
programming language
they used.
And OK, hopefully, we can get
some actual results to show up
on the screen.
Here we go.
So often, when you're starting
interactive queries, you just
want to look at the data.
You want to see what
the format is.
And we can see that actor is
just the username, created_at
is a UTC time string, and
repository_language is the
language that we used.
So we're doing 7-day actives.
We're clearly going to need
to do some kind of
math on this time.
It's hard to do math
over a string.
So what we want to do is we want
to turn this-- we might
be able to come up with a
regular expression that would
do it, but it would
be really nasty.
So BigQuery provides a function
called parse_utc
microseconds.
Oops.
Here we go.
And--
[LAUGHS]
Sorry.
And there's another function
that we want that's called
"UTC microseconds today" that
essentially will just truncate
the time stamp to
the day level.
Because we don't necessarily
care what time of day
something happened, we just
care what day it is.
And so we can see the
results of this
in a couple of seconds.
So now here we have
the time stamps.
I'm going to get rid of
repository_language here
because often, when you're
solving a complex problem,
it's easier to break it down
into easier problems.
So at first, let's just
look at 1-day actives
for the whole site.
So we're getting redundant
values for if someone checked
in multiple times per day
or checked into multiple
repositories per day.
Let's remove some of these
redundant values by doing a
GROUP by day, actor.
So now we have--
awesome.
Oh, yes, and as day.
Thank you.
Do a GROUP BY.
OK, so here we're going
to have these unique
actor and day pairs.
And so, in order to find out how
many of those are per day,
we're going to just wrap this
in an outer SELECT.
So--
oops, day--
we need to group by day again.
And I'll remove that
limit, because we
want all the results.
Group, goop, I cannot
spell today.
This should take a couple
more seconds.
This is a more complex query.
And so I should get
a reasonable
ordering on this one.
There we go.
OK, so here's the number
of 1-day actives for,
essentially, every day.
And we could reparse that day
back into the string value.
OK, so as I was talking about
before, when you're doing a
GROUP BY and there's a lot of
intermediate values, sometimes
it'll, I call it, blow
up one of the shards.
It basically is too many
results to return back.
So what I'm going to do here is
I'm just going to show an
example of how you
would subsample.
So we can also--
oops.
We could filter by where
the hash of the actor.
And then, since we're filtering
dividing by 10, we
need to multiply by 10 here.
And we can get this in
a couple of seconds.
So this is the filtered
version.
And the numbers look
kind of similar.
And you may say, well, how
similar are those?
And so here's the query that
will actually determine how
good of an approximation
that was.
And perhaps this looks like an
intimidating query, but it's
actually really simple.
This is the query I just ran.
This is the unfiltered query.
This is the filtered
query right here.
And we're just joining those
two on day so that we can
compare the various days.
And then we're computing the
error, so the difference over
the expected value times
100, so that we
get the percent error.
And that's giving us the
percent error per day.
And then we just take the
average, so that we get the
average error.
And when we run that, we see
that it's less than 1% error.
So that's a pretty good
approximation.
OK, so that's great.
We have 1-day actives.
But what we really wanted
is 7-day actives.
And so this is a slightly more
complicated query, but we've
seen all these parts before.
So this is the same sampled
query that we had before.
And we're doing a JOIN, just
like we did in the last query,
but this part's a little
bit different.
And this is basically just going
to return all of the
days that anybody was active.
And we're going to play a little
trick in relation to
algebra here.
When you do a JOIN, if there's
multiple things that match the
JOIN key on both the left and
the right, you get the
cross-product.
You get all of the things on
the left with all of the
things on the right.
So here, we're joining
on a constant.
So we're getting all of
the days with all
of the active users.
And what this is going to allow
us to do is then we
filter those by where the day
is within seven days of the
user making a change.
And this allows us to let
someone's change last for
seven days.
And so here we get the
7-day actives.
And there's one more thing that
I want to show that's
going to enable us to get
to this programming
language shoot out.
And what that is is you can
sometimes call it a pivot.
But what we want to do is we
want to create a pseudo field
out of the fields that
we already have.
We want to take the language
that the people are using and
figure out whether they're
statically typed, dynamically
typed, or functional.
And so we can use if statements
here for this.
So you can see, if the
statements is any of these
statically typed languages,
then we'll call it static.
If it's any of these dynamically
typed languages,
we'll call it dynamic.
And I listed a few more
functional ones.
And I also have a regular
expression here to match
anything with LISP, because I'm
a little bit sympathetic
to the functional programming
and I was hoping
that it would do well.
But this is a relatively
straightforward query, once
you get past the ifs.
So those are, essentially, all
the pieces that we need for
this giant query that
I showed you before.
So we have the ifs that
I just showed.
And we have a couple
of aggregations.
And the only difference is we're
using these aggregations
to pull these results back out
through the inner queries.
But we have the same--
where is it--
the same thing with we're
pulling out all of the days.
And essentially, we're doing
the hashed sampling with a
GROUP BY day an active.
And then we're just computing
some to the top.
And hopefully, we can see some
of these results here.
We see that it looks like,
unfortunately, dynamically
typed languages are far more
popular on GitHub than--
probably twice as popular
as static.
And functional is not doing
so well at all.
So I guess now it's settled.
No one has to argue about which
one of these is more
popular any more.
All righty, so hopefully, you
guys have learned a little bit
about what big data is, what
big data means at Google.
Hopefully, you learned a little
bit about how the
architecture works and how
that architecture can
influence the queries you run,
and how to think about what
queries you can run.
Thanks.
Anybody have any questions?
[APPLAUSE]
AUDIENCE: Hi.
Does it support limit paging?
So I could say, SELECT limit, 10
comma 20, 20 comma 30, and
page through my results?
JORDAN TIGANI: You'd have
to do the full limit.
And then you can page through,
once you get those results.
And there is also an n-th, which
only allows you to get
one row at a time.
But if you need to get the
millionth result, n-th can let
you do that.
AUDIENCE: OK.
And also, the small JOIN seems
like a way to get around
denormalizing all of our data,
as long as we have a small
enough table that we would
be joining with.
JORDAN TIGANI: That's
absolutely true.
There's a performance bug right
now, which is why I
didn't show some of
the JOINS live.
The small JOINS are much slower
than they should be.
That's getting faster.
I was hoping we could
have that fixed by
today, but it wasn't.
But I think that also just
shows, with BigQuery, we
release a new version
every week.
It's going to continue
to get better.
Things are going to continue
to get faster.
As more people start using
it, we're going
to get larger clusters.
So hopefully, we can turn
that into a positive.
AUDIENCE: All right,
thank you.
JORDAN TIGANI: Sure.
RYAN BOYD: For instance, the red
state, blue state analysis
that I was doing on the states
was a very small JOIN.
I mean, there's only
50 states.
Each one is red or blue.
So that was one example
that we talked about.
JORDAN TIGANI: Yes?
AUDIENCE: I have a high-level
question.
Let's say, if I have a small
[INAUDIBLE], so to get
properly MySQL to start with.
And later on, the data get
bigger and bigger.
So I have to migrate to this
kind of big data storage.
So what's the kind of
strategy you will
recommend for the developer?
We have to prepare two sets of
SQL when we migrate to a
bigger data set strategy.
Then we have to change over.
JORDAN TIGANI: Do you want to?
RYAN BOYD: Yeah, I
can take that.
Basically, it's really easy
to get data into BigQuery.
You can basically keep track of
what new data you're adding
to your database and every
now and then do
an import into BigQuery.
You could do 1,000
imports a day.
So take your data out of your
SQL database into CSV format
and put it into BigQuery.
You will notice some great
performance gains, when you do
things like aggregation
queries.
So for instance, on that
natality data that I showed,
the 137 million rows, I loaded
that into a MySQL server in a
large instance on EC2 and
ran queries on it.
And doing an average of the
birth weight took about a
minute, whereas BigQuery
took a few seconds.
So I'd really recommend you
keep your SQL database in
order to keep your data up
to date, in order to
serve your data live.
But when you're trying to do
your analytics, then export
that data out of your SQL
database into BigQuery.
You could even do things like
sharding, based off of day.
And you can select from multiple
tables in BigQuery
and union them together in your
results, if you have your
data sharded.
Does that help?
Come up later if you have
any follow-up on that.
AUDIENCE: Can you summarize
what sorts of
public data are available?
RYAN BOYD: Sure.
Where's that question
coming from?
Oh.
Oh, the lights are a little
bit blinding.
Public data, so Wikipedia
revision history, going back
to about two years ago, there's
350 million rows.
You can grab an updated version
of that data set and
load it in yourself.
There's 450 million rows in
that, basically, every
revision made to every
Wikipedia article.
It's really interesting data
to play around with.
We have the natality data that
I just showed you, the birth
certificates.
We have Ngrams.
I'm trying to think of all
the different other ones.
JORDAN TIGANI: Yeah.
So the Ngrams are the
Google Books sets.
We don't have all that much.
And we had a little bit
of a hard time finding
large public data sets.
So if you guys have data sets
that are large and public that
you'd like us to include
in the public
samples, let us know.
And we would love to have more
interesting things out there.
RYAN BOYD: The largest one, I
think, we have is the network
performance data.
I forget what it's called.
JORDAN TIGANI: M-Lab.
RYAN BOYD: M-Lab, yeah.
The M-Lab data set, which is
kind of network performance
data, it's a little hard for
demos because not everyone
understands the underlying
data.
But that is a very large
data set that you
can play around with.
Is there something specifically
that you're
looking for?
No.
All right.
OK?
AUDIENCE: Do you have any tips
for making the development
process cheaper?
So if you're charging by
terabytes of data touched, and
just there in the demo you
touched a few gigs.
I have great ideas for moving
a data warehouse to BigQuery
or log data.
And while it might not consume
a whole lot of disk by your
standards, for my developers
who are not accustomed to
working with BigQuery,
it could get pricey.
RYAN BOYD: We typically look
at it as being less pricey
than alternative solutions.
And we've found customers
that tell us that.
There is a separate charge
for storage than
there is for queries.
So you can upload your
terabytes of data.
And the cost of uploading
that data is cheap.
It's when you run your queries
and you touch the terabytes of
data that you're getting
the cost incurred.
But $35 per terabyte, you
compare that to I started a
bunch of Hadoop instances
running high.
But I think I had 15 machines
that I was running.
And I ended up with a $900 bill
after a couple of days.
That's a lot more expensive,
in my mind, because,
basically, you're keeping those
resources always running.
Whereas, we're only charging you
for the actual queries and
all that you're doing.
And our queries are going across
hundreds and hundreds
of servers to get you
those fast results.
JORDAN TIGANI: And if you do
have data that's that large,
you can use the hash trick to
sample out some of that data
and get a million rows that
they can work on.
And when you have a million
rows, those queries are
actually really cheap, if you're
only touching a couple
of megabytes.
It takes a lot of megabytes
to add up to a terabyte.
RYAN BOYD: The other thing is
actually sharding the data.
So I demoed the sharding on
that 2012, like the market
statistics from 2012.
Google actually does
sharding on a daily
basis, on a weekly basis.
So we have tables for each day
and a table for each week.
So if you're just trying to look
at a smaller portion of
your data to learn and run your
queries on, definitely
shard it up.
And then you can do UNION
queries to join everything
together when you want
to look over a larger
amount of data at once.
Because we're doing those full
table scans, that will really
limit the amount of data that
you touch and it will allow
you to still perform
the real queries.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
JORDAN TIGANI: Somebody
in the back?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
We're trying to use BigQuery
for log analysis.
Can you talk about some of the
potential gotchas that we may
encounter doing so,
specifically
around revolving logs?
So not necessarily keeping the
full, entire history of logs,
but just the last, say,
30 days or something.
JORDAN TIGANI: So we have added
recently a feature that
allows you to set an expiration
time on your tables.
So you can continue to add
tables, and the older ones
will just drop off
as they age out.
We don't have any ways right now
to window your query over
a particular time and particular
set of tables.
RYAN BOYD: But you can specify
them all individually.
JORDAN TIGANI: Right.
RYAN BOYD: The queries can
get a little bit long.
AUDIENCE: Is it possible to
query over a single data set
that contains multiple tables,
so you don't have to do that
union and figure out
programmatically what the set
of tables that you
care about are.
Instead, just query the
whole data set.
JORDAN TIGANI: Not currently.
But I wouldn't be surprised
if it was added
some time in the future.
RYAN BOYD: In the near future.
[LAUGHS]
Nice hint there, Jordan.
JORDAN TIGANI: Thanks.
AUDIENCE: Hey, I was going
to ask, what's
the best append strategy?
I see that you can do it by just
uploading a new CSV and
telling it to add it
to the data set.
Or there's actually an APPEND
command in the API.
Let's say you have sensors
putting in 100,000 records
every day or hour or whatever.
It's like, what's the most
efficient way to add that
stuff in as it comes in live?
JORDAN TIGANI: Especially right
now, I would tend to try
to aggregate that
a little bit.
So rather than doing a whole lot
of little ones, I would do
fewer larger APPENDS.
And if you're going to want to
do a lot of your queries only
over a smaller portion of that,
you might want to use
several tables or
daily tables.
The syntax for including
multiple tables is just a
comma, so you could say, from A
comma B, which confuses some
people because, elsewhere,
that means
join those two tables.
AUDIENCE: So say I
have my database.
And I'm using it to serve it
to my users, so every so
often, I want to use BigQuery
to do some analytics and to
study how things are going.
You mentioned it's all an API.
So I was wondering
which way could I
automate the appending?
Say I want it every week.
I want to have a fresh version
of my database up in BigQuery
to do my analysis.
What would be the best
way to do that?
How does the API look like
for something like that?
RYAN BOYD: I would just do a
cron job, or something like
that, that you would select the
last weeks of data out of
your database.
And I believe MySQL has a
MySQL import function.
I think they probably have an
export function as well that
will generate a CSV
file for you.
And just do that.
And import that data
into BigQuery.
The import process I,
unfortunately, was supposed to
show you, but didn't.
But all you really have to do
was generate your file.
And then you could do the
import through the UI.
And this is the same
thing as you do the
import through the API.
You basically specify the
schema, the table ID, and then
the location of the file
on Cloud Storage.
And there's just a few little,
simple options that you can
specify then.
So you can just regularly import
your data from your
code in a cron job on a weekly
basis, would probably be the
best strategy there.
AUDIENCE: And it would be
just a post to some URL?
RYAN BOYD: Yeah, exactly.
Typically, we upload it through
Google Cloud Storage.
So there's command line binaries
that you can use for
that, or there are libraries, or
you can manually construct
your post to upload it
to Cloud Storage.
And then you just do a post to
BigQuery to insert a new job
to say ingest this data.
AUDIENCE: Thanks.
Thanks.
AUDIENCE: So how long would it
take to import a terabyte of
data from Google Cloud Storage
into BigQuery?
RYAN BOYD: I don't know
on a terabyte of data.
I did the Wikipedia data set
of 450 million rows, and it
was about a half hour process
for the ingestion.
A lot of that, though, is the
ingestion job just sitting in
a queue, because we only
have so many machines
that process ingestion.
So there's a little latency
before the job kicks off, but
the jobs actually go
really quickly.
I don't know how many gigabytes
the Wikipedia data
set was, but it's definitely
not small.
AUDIENCE: So I support
the DOD community.
And the data lives at
the test ranges.
And we're talking petabytes,
not terabytes.
Some of these tools would
be very useful to us for
analyzing those large
data sets.
Is there any process for being
able to get some of these
tools to where our data lives?
JORDAN TIGANI: We don't have a
process like that right now,
but you might contact one
of the salespeople.
If there's the possibility for
really large data sets, they
might be able to come up with
a way to import those in a
one-off thing.
RYAN BOYD: Yeah.
Now that we have compute with
Linux VMs in the cloud, maybe
you can move your data onto our
infrastructure, even if
it's using some proprietary
code.
All right, it looks like that's
the last of the questions.
We do also have a very active
tag on Stack Overflow.
And Michael, up here in the
front row, was actually
answering Stack Overflow
questions while Jordan and I
were speaking So ask your
questions there, or find us
out after the talk.
So thank you, guys.
JORDAN TIGANI: Thanks.
[APPLAUSE]